avec une ferveur unique en france
l'alsace toute entière se prépare à
célébrer joyeusement la nativité noël et
la noël que ponctuent l'arbre toujours
vers apportant avec lui au fond de
chaque homme
ces effluves de résine et je ne sais
quelle pureté descendu tout droit des
montagnes à travers l'oeil du temps
qu'elle et dont l'histoire de cet arbre
que l'on parle symbole de la renaissance
de la terre
ravi jeunes encore au coeur des vosges
il porte aujourd'hui à travers le monde
une délicate coutume alsacienne
[Musique]
et il nous fait évoquer ces noëls du
temps passe et que les siècles ont paré
du halo de poésie et de regrets dont
s'entourent les choses à jamais révolue
alors
voilà alors
un trop cher
lancé par là bas on
alors on sur ces principes janot tour
c'est un texte de 15 121 qui révèle pour
la première fois la présence sur un
marché de sélestat de sapins destinés à
devenir des arbres de noël mais les
images représentant ces arbres
n'apparaissent que beaucoup plus tard
la plus ancienne que nous connaissions
et cette estampe signé joseph quel
bonheur et qui date certainement des
environs de 1790 elle représente une
fête de noël familial avec de nombreux
figurants et un arbre branchu d'essence
imprécise décoré de jouets de poupée et
de bougies allumées tout le décor est là
et cette scène familiale respire déjà
une tradition solidement implanté
quelque en soit l'intérêt que nos
graphiques on peut sans esprit de
clocher lui préférer la petite
illustration si douce et si simple de
benjamin zix dans la pièce où règne un
aimable désordre le petit sapin décoré
d'un bhl trésor et curieusement
suspendus au plafond
ici c'est moins la joie que la tante la
paix de noël que l'on ressent deux
acteurs seulement mais les acteurs
éternelle du miracle de noël
une jeune mère et un petit enfant
endormi dans son berceau traduit avec
tant de finesse aussi par sean o'hair
et balle d'ombré
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui les arbres de noël bresse
sur les places de strasbourg leur
silhouette illuminé et les guirlandes
lumineuses dessinent leurs arabesques
scintillante dans les rues de la ville
la traditionnelle foire de noël le
christ kindle mairie a ouvert ses
inventaires depuis le début du mois de
décembre aux yeux à vis des enfants
[Musique]
il y à quelques 150 ans la foire de noël
se tenait sur l'actuelle place du
château qui portait alors le joli monde
vieux marché aux cerises
on y trouvait les confiseries et des
jouets par milliers écrit frédéric
plutôt que du lac il aujourd'hui
l'excellente historien du strasbourg
illustre la foire de noël émigrés 1830 à
la place kléber où elle se maintint
jusqu'en 1870 plusieurs artistes l'ont
évoqué en ce lieu
edward yu dans une gravure sur bois de
1858 et 1000 find their dans une
aquarelle qu'il situe en 1859 et
théodore leaks enfin en 1861
je
[Musique]
depuis lors la foire de noël déploie ses
fastes populaire color et brouillant
fleurant bon la pâtisserie
le berlingo ici place breuil prémices
des préludes un noël un tant soit peu
matérialiste
on y trouve ses bougies ses cheveux
d'ange ses boules de verre éblouissante
toute cette pacotille et toutes ces
confiseries et ses jouets qui sont
devenus inséparables de l'arbre qui va
se dresser dans d'innombrables foyers à
travers le monde entier
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
hu
et aujourd'hui comme autrefois devant
l'arbre immortel l'émerveillement de
l'enfance reste le même hors du temps
fixée en une image d'intimité de
tendresse et de père
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]